on September 16th 22 year old Masa amini
died after being detained for allegedly
violating Iran's laws requiring women to
wear a headscarf Iranian authorities say
she died of illness but her family said
she fell into a coma after being
mistreated by police
protests sparked by her death have since
rallied groups across Iran's society
from ethnic minorities to school
children and even Oil Workers
thank you
according to human rights groups clashes
with police have killed more than 200
people
but despite the crackdowns and
widespread internet shutdowns videos
have continued to emerge
showing how unrest has spread Beyond
women's rights to a movement that is
calling for an end to strict Theocratic
rule
these demonstrations have now turned
into the most broadly supportive
movement in Iran in more than four
decades
a day after her death amini's funeral
took place in her hometown of success
the ceremony quickly turned into a
protest against the country's morality
police
mourners took off their headscarves in
defiance of the very rules amini was
accused of preaching
a meaning was Kurdish Iranian part of an
ethnic minority that has long accused
the government of discrimination and
neglect after a week of unrest
authorities launched strikes at Kurdish
militant groups across the border in
Iraq saying they were inciting the
protests although there were no visible
separatist slogans in the protests that
followed amini's death
and the demonstrations against Iran's
strict Islamic dress code took on a new
form
on September 20th a woman in the eastern
city of cremon removed her headscarf and
cut her hair in a video that was widely
shared online
it triggered a wave of support from
around the world with celebrities and
women imitating her gesture and posting
videos to social media
that's roughly when the government
restricted access to the internet in
large parts of the country
access to platforms like Instagram and
WhatsApp that have been used to organize
rallies was blocked
the internet cuts through criticism from
businesses
tehran's Chamber of Commerce estimated
the cost of 24 billion dollars for
Industries including I.T services
[Music]
despite the restrictions the protester's
message was taken up by students across
the country
in one case children at an all-girls
school took off their scarves and chased
away a man from the premises throwing
bottles and chanting Shameless
as more crowds to the streets in large
numbers the government used tear gas and
live ammunition to disperse
demonstrations
a particularly deadly incident broke
down the southeast home to another
ethnic minority the belush
on September 30th protesters were seen
walking towards a police station before
being fired upon local human rights
groups say more than 90 people were
killed in what protesters dubbed Bloody
Friday
the government blamed the violence on a
local militant group that has denied any
role in the protests
and then demonstrations spread to one of
the most critical sectors of Iran's
economy oil
in early October workers went on strike
at a number of refineries blocking roads
with stones and chanting slogans in
support of other protests although the
government claimed these strikes weren't
related to amini's death
these strikes highlight another big
problem for the Islamic Republic a
struggling economy due to U.S sanctions
and a number of other issues in the
country and they have a symbolic weight
in Iran it was strikes oil refineries in
1978 much bigger ones than today that
helped bring down the Shah of Iran
Muhammad Reza palavi in the revolution
that established the current Islamic
Republic
in recent years Iran's leaders have
faced several protest movements but have
shown no sign of backing down and today
is no different they claim the
demonstrations are being orchestrated by
foreign enemies and hundreds of
protesters have been brought to trial
but discontent has continued to emerge
across Society disrupting normal life
from this prison that was engulfed by
fire after a clash between detainees and
prison guards to shopkeepers striking
across the country and a major Target of
the demonstrations continues to be one
of the foundations of the Theocratic
State its supreme leader Ali Khamenei
foreign